来 和大家聊聊自媒体的收拾来源
因为每次我直播的时候总是有人在想法问
说你的收拾来源都有哪些呀 你靠什么政策呀
聊聊读书博助怎么争钱呀
我想很多人就需要一个确定性
我要去做一件事 我的方向什么呀 我往哪个方向努力呀 对不对
咱们想到啥呀 俩啥吧
我给大家聊聊支持博助怎么争钱
因为别的咱也不懂吧 就我自己怎么争钱
我把大家我把我的情况更加简单说一下
首先第一个我的收拾来源是流量的费用
有些收拾一条视频泡了 有人在下面留言上你投了多少钱
首先给大家普及一条
就是如果你在短期冰击台上卖东西 你需要给平台交钱
那就要广告费 对吧
流量费 对吧但是我们这种呢 是属于投稿了
简单来说就是你们能到短期冰击台就是因为我们投了稿
所以我们是给平台带来带来流量的 所以我们是有稿费的
那因为我呢
拍东西的标是我希望我拍东西我用的
而且我很少位拍的视频
华更多的经历 所以每天有拍十分钟之类就拍一条视频
我的飞用的话 我大概把就是流量的华的两一台
我差不多一个月一万多两万块钱 接近两万块钱吧 大概是这样的
我刚才非常讲前面的一些就是
我的流量 你看我的粉丝量表达 但是我流量并不大
什么意思 其实就是你可以把我的收拾打个对折
可能人家一百万两百万粉丝的流量
那个流量肯定是超过我的
我的方向并不是特别用心 我关注的是
是内容本身有没有加势
流量对我来说不是很重要 所以我的流量流量的稿费是打手的
但是差不多一个月有两万块钱 就是大家里面能看得到
第二的话就是带货的费用 因为我自己不带货
我呢
不懂别的东西 我还在去比特别东西不好 我有没有好卖
我不想浪费这个时间
连输月是一样的 我说只放我自己看不得输
是我自己看不得输 这个输 我觉得不错 我在挂来上面 而且大家很想看
我在
直播电话什么 现在多少钱 都多少到买了没有 当然 几乎没有看到我带输
我最多的情况就是拿过了一本输给大家读
我说最近看里面输 输是什么 然后把输挂出车上
我也不去什么影
什么话输影 大家卖东西很多老会都知道
但这个费用我差不多一个月一万吧
有的时候少点击击打仙 有时候多点就一万多 打击是这样一个
大概这样一个情况
那我为什么讲 前面那个呢 就是如果你专门买输的
好 我这种属于那种很冷的 然后机会就不卖
是靠大家 觉得这个输不错 那我听胡子 听了这么多 我就带胡子了买 大家是这样一个情况
所以如果你专业买输的话 你买的可能屁 屁这个多
我就知道 我好多朋友就是一个月 国卖输卖的是好多 打击十万上百万只有的
粉丝量肯定比我的少少太多了 但是人家是有这个费用的 所以这个费用
你们不能把我 不能以我为主 为我这个数字的标准
但是如果你像我要卖的话 你可以做一个标准
这是第二个 第二个费用
然后还有什么费用 你们看到的 还有费用广告费
我呢 不做统告 但是我能看到广告报价 就是会有人跟你报价
说你给我做一条广告多少钱 最佛的报价是20
那个事已经是两年前了 我就剥钱 发脑 我该可以看了一件
给我的报价有五万 没有八万的
然后呢 差不多你会认为五万块钱嘛 对于 结一个商量五百钱 但是因为我不接统告
所以我不知道最后还有什么责任 什么东西 我不太理解
所以我就很大说 人家给我报了价 评价来 就是五万八万 你调视频
但是我没结果 这个不做数
这三个呢 就是大家能看到的
你们也他们能想到的 就是
流量的费用 然后卖货的费用 然后卖货的费用 然后卖负用 然后卖负用 然后卖负用 然后卖负用
然后还有一个就是广告的费用 对吧
那还有些事你们可能看不到的 比如说卖货的费用
因为我自己不外客 虽然我陷下以前陷下想客 但我现在不外客
因为现在这个网络上卖客的口味都不太好
那我不过 这不去跟那个钱 所以我想卖客 我也不想开那个嘛
但是呢 从今年八月份开始 七月份的时候我们在陷下做了一个陷下活动
然后呢 当时是AG嘛 就是我们来的时候 什么酒店费用 什么费用都是均塌子 大家没有想客费 但是均塌的费用
然后很多的我去参加一下 有人就是 参加不了
所以我当然想不到做了陷伤去 后来呢 想给大家演示一个怎么这么账的正在小钱的费用
这么账的正在小钱 我们就把陷伤了就收费了 很多人都知道最开始收的是10块钱吗 四
然后每增加以前我就开始上漲 四十九 九十八 现在是一百二十八
八一份九一份十一份十一份十一份 现在应该是四千不到四千八百人
每个月一千多吧 每个都一千多人 那么差不多因为我还要交税 还要平台的费用 差不多一个月几万块钱
这么一个费用 这赚兰的费用 赚兰的费用 赚兰的费用 当然你可以赚兰 赚兰 赚兰的费用 很多人能争很多的
但是我不做 所以我有赚兰的费用 你觉得像我这样的 而且你可以这么做 这是一个费用
然后还有一个费用的话就是社群的费用 我是有社群的 但是我不宣传 大家都知道吧 就是我基本上不宣传
很多人说胡子哥 你的社群怎么加入 我说你自己想啊 你能加上这些门卡 你找不着就算了
为什么 如果你连这少不了的话 我的社群就要确实做动的 我不会告诉你 经过第二个这三个怎么做 我不是这样 就是我告诉一个方向 你自己做动作做
所以如果你连社群都找不着的话 我也不希望你加 所以我又不再这是宣传
大概每个月结论会见 可以这样 可以每个月结论会见 这个这个收益
然后那个收益我很佛心 觉得不合适所以是可以退 但是他中间门的平台上的钱退不了 所以我有不想宣传这个事情
你就是到有个打个结论会见吧
然后还有一个收益的话 写书的肥油 今天我刚刚收到一个消息 就是第一半 第12次一刷了
然后我看我的片级说差不多每个月一次一刺一刺
我的第一次一刷是两万刺 第二些刺一刷也是两万刺 后面一刷几 我不知道可能是几天刺
可能是一万刺可能两万刺 我太了解 十二次一刺一刺差不多 反正十几万刺可能是有的
然后我看我的 看了一下我上一次搞费的收益 七万多块钱吧 差不多只剩下来每个月
我们就按三个月一次一刺吧 每个月差不多两三块钱 大概有这么个费
所以像我这种比较福气的 因为很多老会都知道我的 主要收益是在投资一起上 二一上的投资
然后我做短的平就是孙孙十二位的一个事情 每周二晚上
然后有一个干货的交付的直播 然后每天花十分钟路过视频就债了情况
但是只有这个就是这个样子的话 每个月差不多也有十万块钱的收益嘛 就这么几个大的收益 大家可以对比一些情况
就是每个地方如果你有很努力的话 就是你都替我收入路稿
所以做支持不得住 肯定是赚钱的
肯定是赚钱的 这几个方向都是写定的 所以如果你想做的话 我真的是推荐您做
每天看看说学习 要把自己的一些所得 分享给大家
对吧 你孙孙被要推成他小钱嘛
像我的这种徒徒服 要是不动动动力的 哪都不行的人
所以还得推荐哪做
然后就算你不赚钱 我给大家说学习 我的外地好处吧
其实也没给大家去讲过 就是你每天会养成一个习惯
你每天会养成一个习惯 每天要给大家做一个输输
实际上输输的过程就是一个输的过程 因为你讲的时候你不会嘛
你就知道那个支持的奉细的 那怕再点的你讲的时候就一定是不会
那个奉细在哪 你需要把他补上 他是一个很快的
IP都比款 还有的话呢 短视频的一个好处 什么呢 就是
他能给你大概就影响了一种东西 我想的 你不好就算的
因为说我以前 我大家都知道我已经做资讯
然后每个月就是有一些资讯的费用 我现在很少做资讯的
但是偶尔也会接 有时候是有时候手想花花脑子
那你会发现你的这个粉丝量来点
所以收入屁以前 高很多呀 跟基本上
你可以算一些不差不多我 有人请你吃饭
然后聊到天儿 聊到余洞饭 两三个小时
三四小时差不多 仍然会给你红包
平均下来 有小时约等一样了钱吧
大概是这么一个飞用 但是我很少接
还有一个就是还是已经了 你也还不到
因为你粉丝多了以后呢 然后你的口味还是正的这样子
所以有一些人会给你接上去 旁边有些认识的
一些社会的资讯的人是一些企业家呀
然后你和他们在教这个公众中
你可以从他们身上学到好的东西
这些东西都是不行的
所以就两件事情吧
我觉得第一个就是 他确实是有时候值得你做
第二个就算没有说出
他能全行为的提升你的影响力
然后你的思考能量的血腻能力
对吧 就这个其实是有百分之五一海的